à une semaine de la présentation tant
attendue du plan de relance à 100
milliards d'euros on est l'économie
française quel bilan peut-on tirer les
indicateurs publiés cet été sur l'impact
réel de la crise sur l'activité
on en parle tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir bonsoir
jacques bienvenu j'espère que vous avez
passé d'excellentes vacances ça fait
plaisir de vous revoir en tout cas
bonsoir stéphanie j'espère que pour vous
aussi les vacances ont été très bonnes
années en cette rentrée jacques avant
l'annoncé du plan de relance
comment se porte l'économie française
est bien stéphanie il faut dire qu'à la
vérité l'économie française ne se porte
pas bien
elle ne se portait déjà pas bien avant
la crise du coc vide 19 et il faut se
rappeler que le dernier trimestre de
2014 le quatrième trimestre avait été
marqué par des mauvais chiffres pour la
croissance économique alors évidemment
là dessus on a eu la crise le
confinement est évidemment là encore on
est dans une situation qui est une
situation tout à fait exceptionnelle de
crise bien suivre on attend le plan de
relance on attend d'ailleurs avec une
certaine impatience
mais il faut aussi ajouter que cette
crise n'a pas frappé que la france et
que nos voisins nos partenaires sont eux
aussi très vertement tout fait alors
jacques concrètement où en sommes nous à
quelques jours de la rentrée
et bien si on écoute les prévisions qui
sont faites soit par l'insee soit pour
le gouvernement on est face à une chute
de croissance à une récession qui est
tout à fait historique -9% pour l'insee
-11% pour le gouvernement ce sont des
chiffres qui dépassent et de très loin
ce qui avait été atteint lors de la
crise de 2008 2009 après il faut
comprendre que cette crise elle n'a pas
fait que toucher que la france et c'est
aussi ce tacle qui d'une certaine
manière
entendre un espèce de supplément de
crise quand évidemment l'allemagne
l'italie l'espagne vont mal et bien nous
allons mal
nous aussi
il faut encore dire une chose c'est
creed elle a touché l'ensemble des
secteurs
que ce soit les services où que ce soit
l'industrie comme l'industrie
aéronautique et le point important c'est
que alors que maintenant l'activité est
repartie dans l'industrie et bien cette
activité ne concerne que 72% des
capacités productives elles étaient à
peu de choses près avant la crise entre
80 et 82 %
autrement dit il manque bien de
l'activité même comparé à 2019 à nous
entendre jacques nous sommes loin de la
reprise en v que certains économistes
espéraient en juin dernier
ah oui tout à fait tout à fait stéphanie
vous avez si la reprise ressemble à
quelque chose de manière graphique ça
serait un petit peu aux signes racine
carrée oui bien sûr il ya eu une
remontée depuis le fond de la crise mais
après on voit très bien que ça stagne ou
que ça tend vers la stagnation alors une
chose qui est importante à comprendre
c'est que avec évidemment les huit
semaines de confinement on a eu une
chute extrêmement forte de la
consommation et il était tout à fait
normal qu'avec le déconfinement fin mai
juin et puis en juillet eh bien il ya
une forme de rattrapage de cette
consommation
ainsi sur le marché de l'automobile est
bien en juillet on constate que les
français ont acheté à peu près 180 mille
voitures neuves ces quatre pour cent de
plus que ce qui avait été acheté en
juillet 2019 mais si on regarde
globalement l'activité des sept premiers
mois de l'année donc de janvier à
juillet et bien il manque 400 mille
voitures aux achats ou nouvelles
immatriculations
autrement dit il manque plus de 30 % des
achats de voitures et cesta un petit peu
le problème on n'a pas soufflé la
reprise du poste du déconfinement 1 n'a
pas été suffisante pour effacer ce qui
s'était passé dans le confinement est ce
que l'on peut dire pour les voitures et
bien évidemment cela peut se dire pour
l'ensemble des
autres biens manufacturés les
frigidaires les machines à laver les
appareils de télévision etc mais propre
à la france eh bien non et c'est ce que
je disais au début on constate si vous
voulez là on a les estimations qui sont
faites par le fonds monétaire
international
on constate que la france se situe 1 je
dirais dans une forme de moyenne de ce
qui s'est passé en europe alors bien sûr
la france a de meilleurs résultats que
litanie qui était de très loin le pays
le plus touché
mais elle est à peu près à égalité avec
l'espagne et alors ce qui est
intéressant c'est de voir que enfin la
france a moins soudas plus souffert
excusez moi le plus souffert que
l'allemagne ou que la grande-bretagne
alors on voit bien le problème jacques
mais alors si l'on regarde au delà de
l'europe parce que c'est la même chose
alors oui mais là encore yann des
différences qui sont tout à fait
significatives on voit et là encore ce
sont des estimations qui sont faites par
le fonds monétaire international sur la
base d'ailleurs des comptabilités
nationales des différents pays eh bien
on voit que la chine est le pays qui a
récupéré de cette crise le plus littéral
c'est intéressant parce que la crise
elle a commencé en chine
en réalité et il ya eu plusieurs régions
de chine qui ont été complètement
confinés pendant de nombreuses semaines
eh bien c'est la chine qui redémarrent
le plus vite
après vous avez les pays émergents qui
eux aussi rodez alors moins vite que les
filles mais il redémarre nous nettement
plus vite que les pays développés et ce
qui est très intéressant c'est de voir
que la la crise elle semble avoir touché
en priorité les pays développés qui
visiblement ne récupéreront pas cette
crise avant 2022 alors est ce que cela
veut dire que le commis 19 à accélérer
le basculement l'économie mondiale vers
l'asie oui oui tout à fait et c'est
d'ailleurs l'une des leçons que l'on
peut tirer de ces crimes on voit bien
que avec 7
ifs et bien le phénomène je dirais de
basculement du centre de gravité
économique du monde bien ce phénomène il
c'est d'une certaine manière accélérée
on voit par exemple la sur le graphique
que le poids
un des pays industrialisés des
etats-unis de l'union européenne ou du
japon et bien ce poids ne cesse de
diminuer et que aujourd'hui on est au
point de rattrapage entre le niveau de
ces pays
et puis le niveau de pays comme la chine
l'inde et la russie
un dernier point jacques est il vrai que
la france a fait en définitive plus pour
le soutien son économie que ses voisins
comme le prétendent jean castex et son
ministre de l'économie bruno le maire
oui alors là sur ce point si vous voulez
je suis désolé de faire de la peine un
petit peu aux membres de notre
gouvernement
mais très clairement quand on dit que la
france est le pays qui a fait en
proportion le plus d'efforts pour son
économie
c'est tout simplement fou si vous voulez
ce n'est pas vrai alors que ce soit pour
ce qui est des dépenses budgétaires qui
ont été enregistrées dans les différents
pays et on voit que en termes de
dépenses budgétaires bien la france se
traîne derrière que soient les
états-unis l'allemagne
même l'italie même l'italie en a fait
plus que nous ou si l'on reprend
maintenant la question des garanties de
liquidité bon là la situation était un
petit peu meilleure mais malgré tout on
voit que la france elle est assez loin
derrière l'allemagne derrière la
grande-bretagne et qu'en fait même
l'italie a des chiffres qui sont
meilleurs que les nôtres donc ce qui est
très intéressant c'est que la france ou
d'abord à moins réagi que la plupart de
ses partenaires
mais surtout elle a réagi plus tard elle
a pris du retard parce que les plans de
relance ont été annoncés en allemagne au
mois de juin et fin juin début juillet
en italie
alors pour conclure jacques à vous
attendez
et qu'attendez vous du plan de relance
et non pardon est ce que vous attendez
ce plan de relance mais y arriver avec
anxiété
oui tout à fait tout à fait stéphanie
pour les raisons que j'ai dit c'est
parce que en réalité la france a pris du
retard alors que ce soit en volume que
ce soit si vous voulez en dépenses où
que ce soit en temps en fait il faut
être sérieux
ce plan de relance qui vient d'être
retardé si vous voulez il était annoncé
pour mardi dernier il est maintenant
annoncée pour jeudi prochain
ce plan de relance il aurait dû être
annoncée au minimum fin à la fin du mois
de juillet donc il y a un vrai problème
aujourd'hui dans la politique économique
du gouvernement et tout ce que l'on peut
espérer c'est que quand le plan de
relance sera enfin annoncé eh bien on
trouve dedans à la fois des éléments en
matière de volumes mais aussi des
éléments en matière je dirais de
d'agenda redisons de séquences
d'engagement de ses dépenses qui nous
permet au moins de rattraper les forts
qui a pu être consentis par nos
partenaires et nos voisins merci jacques
et on compte sur vous évidemment pour
nous décrypter en ce fameux plan de
relance